je voudrais avoir une pensée pour la
famille de Lola
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord ce crime
un qualifiable à plonger les Français et
la France dans un état de sidération
d'ailleurs on s'en rend compte chacun a
pris un peu de temps pour réagir
tellement ce crime métatros ce crime il
s'inscrit dans un contexte très
particulier qui est celui d'une
augmentation de la délinquance et
notamment des homicides et des
tentatives d'homicides les chiffres sont
implacables
cette augmentation de la délinquance
elle s'inscrit aussi avec un sentiment
d'impunité de plus un peu important et
il y a deux causes à cela nous n'avons
pas de politique pénale dans notre pays
je le dénonce systématiquement à
longueur de plateau à longueur
d'interview à longueur d'intervention il
n'y a pas de politique pénale d'une part
et nous avons un problème de crédibilité
de la peine en France aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui génère évidemment ce sentiment
d'impunité qui conduit aussi à ses
crimes mais attendez le crime de Lola
c'est aussi le crime de l'errance et ces
terrances qui est de plus en plus
importante dans les métropoles tous ceux
qui habitent dans les métropoles de
l'errance passe
elle vivait chez sa sœur
c'est le crime de l'errance qui est de
plus un peu importante dans les
métropoles et les grandes villes en
France c'est une réalité et cette
errance elle s'incarne dans quoi dans
une étrangère sans papiers et il faut
arrêter nous sommes des responsables
politiques il faut arrêter de vouloir
caricaturer ou vouloir insulter ceux qui
peuvent dénoncer que une grande partie
de ces délinquance violente de rue et
nous le voyons assez régulièrement et
tragiquement à Paris mais aussi à Nantes
à Strasbourg ou à Rennes c'est
délinquance violente de rue et le fait
de d'étranger en situation irrégulière
et notamment des déboutés de droits
d'asile c'est une délinquance qui ne
faut pas
d'étranger en situation
je reprécise mes propos alors n'allez
pas ne m'amenez pas ce que vous voulez
là vous voulez m'amener je n'irai pas je
vous voudrez je vous amener je vois je
vois depuis 48 heures parce que
évidemment quand on est face à une
irresponsabilité y compris par rapport à
l'exécutif évidemment il vaut mieux
attaquer les autres
je dis qu'une partie de la délinquance
violente de rue et le fait d'étrangers
en situation irrégulière et moi je ne
confonds pas je vous le dis très
clairement je ne comprends pas les
étrangers et les étrangers en situation
irrégulière parce que ceux qui nous
accusent de faire la Mali âme ce sont
eux qui font l'amalgame en ne voulant
pas poser les faits et la réalité parce
qu'il est urgent de pouvoir remédier à
cela et aujourd'hui il est important
l'urgence elle est là madame Atalaya
c'est d'avoir une politique pénale
dédiée à la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine là nous n'en n'avons pas et
le deuxième aspect c'est d'avoir une
politique effective de reconduite à la
frontière